eight news now is your local election
headquarters election day now just 20
days away Christian casarez is live in
studio with a look at a big topic on the
ballot that's right Brian well there are
three questions in the ballot this year
number one is putting Equal Rights
Amendment in the state constitution
question number two involves minimum
wage and question number three is Open
primary and ranked choice of voting so
here at 8 news now we're going to be
talking about all these three questions
but today we are focusing on question
number one
people to understand that not everyone
is treated fairly Tristan Reese is
visiting Las Vegas for this year's out
and equals workplace Summit the largest
lgbtq focused conference in the world
which helps create diversity and
inclusion in the workplace most of us
just want to go to work work hard do a
good job and then go home that issue at
the Forefront in the upcoming elections
in Nevada question one proposes an
amendment to add new language to the
Nevada constitution that would guarantee
equal rights regardless of race sex
gender identity sexual orientation age
disability and natural origin if
approved although we had the Supreme
Court decision the boss talk decision
that protected lgbtq people in the
workplace there's so many other issues
Health Care housing you know benefits
that are still being questioned and an
attempt to deter at the state levels
Aaron uritus without an equals tells us
the legislative efforts across multiple
States is a reminder that lgbtq workers
are not fully protected and the fight
for equal rights for all needs to
continue it's very bad for business to
be anti-lgbtq that has been proven 25
years ago it was the reverse she says
the journey has been nothing but easy
some arguing the legislation needs to
include religion and not being pro-woman
for this attendee equality means working
together and we get to have younger
folks as well and we're able to teach
them that this didn't happen by accident
it didn't happen by Magic it happened
through really hard work through
dedication
all right so we're going to be looking
into questions two and three next week
and just a reminder early voting starts
on October 22nd election day is November
8th so you can check out 8newsnow.com to
help voice your vote Krishna Casa does 8
News Now